hi Barbie welcome back to New rockstars
I'm Jessica Clemens and this is a
re-breakdown of the digital release of
the Barbie movie yay it's finally
available originally and allegedly this
movie was supposed to Premiere digitally
September 5th but the date was pushed to
September 12th ahead of its IMAX release
in theaters featuring an unheard of
post-credits scene unfortunately that
post-credit scene won't be revealed
until September 22nd when the IMAX
releases it in theaters regardless I'm
here to re-break it down for you once
upon a time here at new rockstars I
broke down the digital release of
wakanda forever and just like that we
break down I'm going to talk about the
pieces we missed the first time around
Voss did the original breakdown Tommy
and I did the trailer breakdowns so I'll
be pointing out things I found that
weren't in those videos if there's
something you're like oh just good you
actually missed I didn't nope nah get
out of here boss Tommy or pass Jessica
already touched on it let's get into it
and if you haven't already be sure to
subscribe to the Deep dive and break
room channels as well collect all the
channels in the new rockstars Network
and one of the best ways to support the
new rockstars channel is to check out
some of the incredible merch options at
nerd riot.shop they're dropping new
designs all the time so swing by nerd
riot.shop next time you want to show off
your favorite nerd fandom maybe they'll
make a shirt with my face on it don't
buy it people will send you to prison
with that either way we open this
fantastic movie with shot for shot
parody of Stanley Kubrick's 2001 Space
Odyssey specifically the Donna Mann
scene which in an interview with real
blend podcast Greta mentions a lot of
stuff we actually didn't know about this
this wasn't the only Kubrick reference
the Mattel boardroom of men was inspired
by the war room and Doctor Strangelove
they're also shining each other which is
a direct call out to The Shining another
great Stanley Kubrick movie they shot
this parody scene using their own
version of a front screen projection
just like Kubrick did front screen
projection is when you have the
projection going directly onto the
screen and in front of the projector and
screen is the subject it's some very
like old school and Camera visual
effects Works additionally she mentions
Kubrick is a paragon of a certain
masculine filmmaking and he is and I
feel it in his film so that beauty and
like taking the dawn of man and turn it
into Barbie is sort of poetic we've been
introduced to 1959 black and White
swimsuit Barbie but I'm about to list
off every Barbie we see at the beginning
from left to right we have 92's totally
hair Barbie live action Barbie from 1971
1965's Barbie astronaut 1961's
registered nurse Barbie 1960s busy gal
designer Barbie with her portfolio case
1961's Barbie American airline
stewardess 1983's great shaped Barbie
fitted like the one we see in Toy Story
and at the end is 1985's Peaches and
Cream Barbie then were introduced to
2020's park ranger doll Barbie 2017's
tennis star Barbie 2015's National
Geographics astrophysicist Barbie and a
little further down the line we have
2019's vet pet career day Barbie 2011's
architect Barbie 2004's presidential
candidate Barbie 2017's nurse Barbie
1990s flight time Barbie but this one
has pants instead of a little skirt 1975
gold medal Barbie 2010's news anchor
Barbie or reporter Barbie whichever you
prefer 2022's hockey Barbie 1995's
firefighter Barbie 1985's astronaut
Barbie and in 2019's judge Barbie and
some of these Barbies are different from
the original doll like gold medalist
Barbie has a prosthetic leg and Pet Vet
Barbie is in a wheelchair we learn
immediately from Helen Mirren that
Barbie has her passed what she
originally was thought to be and became
everything more or at least something
for everyone she's more than a swimsuit
model she's everything then we see the
little girl she inspires rhythmic
gymnast Barbie and paramedic Barbie pop
star Barbie and salon stylist Barbie
pasta Chef Barbie and Dr doll Barbie and
what I love about this montage is not
every little girl is dressed exactly
like her Barbie you can wear whatever
you have in your house as long as you
feel like pop star Barbie you got it
this is coming from me who was extremely
poor as a child and sometimes it all
lies in accessibility we get an overhead
shot of our Barbie and we get a glimpse
of the little floaties which you can now
finally purchase Rodrigo prito the DP
and Greta Gerwig worked on layering the
colors using Jacques Demi's film The
Umbrellas of cherborg Rodrigo really
popped off with this movie and this is
the same man deeping killers of the
flower Moon that's insane like this this
man this man is doing kills of the
flower Moon and also doing the Barbie
movie of course it's gonna look
beautiful as Barbie wakes up Margot
Robbie's name appears on the screen and
it feels like a sound stagey sitcom then
notice how she follows the camera it
doesn't really follow her later it's
obvious when Barbie is falling out of
the shots and messing up that every day
is perfect in Barbie land our Barbie
just isn't additionally if you didn't
know you can basically buy all of the
Barbie movie wardrobe for your actual
Barbie dolls we see Barbie delivering
milk there is a got milk Barbie but I
love a Barbie delivering soy milk that
just sounds perfect to me the beautiful
sky and mountains are all painted with
prieto's amazing crew they lit it
perfectly to give that 50 Sound Stage
musical feel these 50s 70s iconic styles
from back in the day seeped through and
work so well because Barbie is Disco but
Barbie also came from the 50s she's an
icon in both decades also did you notice
Barbie is too big for her dream house
almost like every single Barbie doll
ever made this was a note Katie Spencer
and Sarah Greenwood the set designers
thought about so every house mostly
everything you see in Barbie land is 23
smaller than it should be that's insane
just like the actual doll size to like
the doll toys to help achieve
practicality they use sticky stuff on
her Mark to keep Margo's shoe in place
and she was actually holding onto a bar
to keep her feet perfectly Barbie Arch
this mirror shot was inspired by Ladies
Man directed by Jerry Lewis almost the
same shot for shot look I'm obsessed
with the fridge being in the chimney
breast Katie Spencer mentioned it's a
hidden secret that kids would like as a
toy I also like the Sarah Greenwood and
Greta Gerwig coming together on the idea
that there can't be walls for the Barbie
house but like a house needs walls to
stand up so they made these giant
Chimneys in the middle of their
structures to hold them all up Greta has
mentioned that the Barbies have no walls
so they can wave to each other but she
also has mentioned in another interview
that they don't have wall so they can't
hide so when she's failing she can't
hide from it Barbie's seamless morning
routine is inspired by Gene Kelly's
morning transition in American and Paris
and every Barbie Dream House comes with
a bird-like mailbox and margos is
clearly the flamingo Midge never wears
pink in this movie I noticed this
watching it the second time and this
really caught me we passed the movie
theater playing the Wizard of Oz and at
the end of this movie we get a
ceremonious like homage to everyone
receiving their gifts just like the Tin
Man The Lion and the Scarecrow got in
The Wizard of Oz but Dorothy like Barbie
doesn't want to stay in this Fantasy
Land she wishes to go back to the real
world so it's kind of the exact same
premise the Barbie flag is blue and two
shades of pink instead of a bird or a
bunch of stars they have a pink seashell
and it's sick as hell this booming
camera we're actually seeing right now
are the same props featured in the
promotional interviews following the
movie's release and there's a painting
near the ceiling of the Nobel Prize
ceremony that has different variations
of Barbies from the inspiring women's
series or just signature dolls from left
to right the ones that I could find we
have 90s Air Force Barbie Barbie career
pediatrician and I think this is Debbie
Harry's like Blondie Barbie it's hard to
make out with all these weird gradient
colors Barbie winter sports Barbie
career eye doctor Amelia Earhart Barbie
Barbie fashionista's doll I think this
is the 1980s just black Barbie and I
think this is Gloria Estefan's Barbie on
the mic with the earrings the Barbies on
Barbie Mount Rushmore that we see later
are 1959 swimsuit Barbie which we saw at
the beginning of the movie original
Christie from 68 the first
African-American Barbie the first Asian
Barbie with a very offensive name from
81 and the California dreamed Teresa the
first Latina Barbie from 87. then we see
our Ken and if you haven't noticed this
definitely ain't a man's world let me
tell you we're at 18 Easter eggs and not
a single one is about Ken Barbie was the
star and Ken was just there even at the
beginning of the movie he's just not
needed it's also been revealed by Greta
that all the background actors have
experienced as professional dancers
their choreographer said this dancers
their bodies always have a direction and
that's different than sort of normal
people so I Greta thought that was in
the conception of Barbie land it's a
soundstage musical so that's why they're
all easy to move around like that the
building to the right says yay every day
which feels like the playoff when she
says yay space and the building further
down has the Barbie fairy then we meet
Alan lovable weird looking Allen
originally Jonathan Graw was actually
supposed to play this part but due to
scheduling conflicts and covet it just
didn't work out but we got Michael Sarah
and I genuinely think I like Michael
there are more it's very kooky and funny
one of the first things I was attracted
to was the speed at which the Barbie
spoke especially Margot Robbie it felt
like Perfection began at this unfiltered
confidence and maturity it was revealed
an amazing interview with letterbox
Greta said it's inspired by his girl
Friday she also had Margot Robbie watch
Philadelphia Story to emulate Catherine
Hepburn and how stoic she is in the
story when a woman starts falling apart
and eventually finds herself just like
Barbie then we're taken to Barbie disco
like the earlier sequence watch as the
camera moves and the Barbies follow the
camera their bodies pointed in the
direction of the cameras this is all
Perfection they eat sleep breathe it the
Ken's jumpsuits were inspired by the
1968 Ken some cans in the background
have solid gold sleeves and front
pockets that are also like solid gold
but it's still different from simu's
outfit I don't know why I think this is
just interesting that Issa learned the
old choreography arrived on set then was
told it changed she then learned the new
choreography of the day of and she's
still cutting it up look at her go and I
am sorry but Kingsley AKA gravic is the
best thing to me I'm so in love with him
in this movie he's just such a goober
the entire way through
when the other Barbies asked Barbie to
run towards the water our Barbie plants
her feet on the ground I didn't notice
this until re-watching the movie The
Foley is absolutely stepping and falling
into sand and we know damn well that's
not real sand when she falls we hear the
sound of the impact and the sand
sprinkles back down it's an insane
amount of attention to detail and gives
us so much Whimsy without even noticing
it this shot of Barbie walk into the
weird Barbie's house was inspired by The
Red Shoes the house was inspired by the
house in Psycho and her hair is inspired
by Catherine devenues from The Umbrellas
of cherborg I don't know if she's
actually using it but weird Barbie uses
this metallic Crystal like fortune
teller just to remind us that this is a
doll's house that belongs to a little
girl so you know you get those little
accessories that you make and add to it
the Barbie user guide that details how
to leave Barbie land just looks like a
small booklet of different Barbie user
guys combined together to look like a
Bible it even has the same morning
labels at the bottom one shot energy
I'll I'll try one I'll try one if it
doesn't wake me up I'm gonna be pissed
[Music]
[Applause]
I know Kung Fu
[Music]
okay I'm gonna try the focus ones now
okay one shot is really all I need I
think they both clashed in me and now I
don't know where I'm at begin your
transformation with one shot energy
today by going to one shotenergy.com new
rockstars for 10 off your order I am
going crazy I am an insane person I have
to go see a musical
let's go sit in a theater oh my God one
of the coolest things they did was shoot
this Montage going in and out of the
real world they're basically like
stagnant and the crew members are
pooling the sets every bit of motion in
this scene is done by someone physically
moving it Barbie and Ken's outfits here
are inspired by the 1994's hot skating
Barbie we know those rollerblades are
the Impala skate ones if you were like
me and losing your mind in the middle of
the pandemic you bought a pair of Impala
roller skates which is also funny
because they had a surge of sales during
the pandemic literally everyone was
roller skating in the middle of the
pandemic and Greta was riding this movie
at the same time so I wonder if she knew
that this would make it into the movie
probably Ken having his dawn of Ken
moment starts getting masculine images
thrown his way and I hate it Washington
Lincoln Alexander Hamilton all men
tailgating party with like five beers
okay go men golf Mount Rushmore cowboy
on a horse shooting a gun in the sunset
then riding that horse aggressively
soccer in the rain cause it's only for
men high five in your bro during
push-ups because yeah that's normal
unnamed male baseball team fist bumpy
men Washington Crossing the Delaware
again another man Greece
lightning very manly just you know
stocks and a man looking at what we
assume are more stocks or maybe crypto
you know it's just man things Two Bros
arm wrestling at work a slam dunk and
Rocky Balboa well I think
it's just more so Sylvester Stallone
only in fur coats which this was the
inspiration for Ken's fur coat I hate
this scene but God the masculinity
oozing from it is perfection when we go
back to Barbie she gets flashbacks of
Sasha playing with Barbie dolls she's
playing with the 2016 fashionista Barbie
the budget for the Barbie dolls in this
movie is impressive but it also makes
sense because it's a Mattel movie the
Teen Angst and harsh attitude leads us
to believe that she's the one that has
the connection to Barbie making them
both sad though you know if you're
watching this we've seen the movie we
know it's Gloria her mom as Sasha grows
up and doesn't want to play with dolls
it's making Gloria sad and that's
billing into the stereotypical Barbie's
life Greta mentioned that her mom was
always cautious of letting her play with
Barbies because you know they're Barbies
Barbies come with a lot of baggage and
you don't know how that impression will
fall into your kid she decided to answer
that in the movie if this this is true
of Barbie you know what else is true and
it resonated with me because of this
scene specifically Barbie begins seeing
the beauty and Humanity even in its
flaws and it's Barbie literally the most
perfect thing on the planet in the
sequence we're learning that though
Barbie is perfect being a human having
emotions passions just living beats that
I wish I would have seen this when I was
like eight years old because there is
Beauty in humanity there's also Beauty
and being a Barbie so I digress these
cubicles are inspired by Jacques tati's
film play time if you haven't seen that
movie you got to I'm sure a lot of the
Mattel building scenes were based off of
this movie those movies are just weirdly
beautiful it's like a painting you want
to put your hand in after getting off
the phone with the FBI agent Aaron talks
about 10 years ago how Skippers showed
up at someone's house in Key West and
asked to babysit the kids during the
call with the FBI agent behind his head
we see an article that says she demanded
to babysit the kids so this FBI agent
has been on Barbie cases for a while
Will Ferrell's character also
acknowledges the Skipper Key West
accident in the boardroom later Gloria
Doodles a sad Barbie on her Mattel
Watermark paper which is the official
seal of Mattel she's also singing closer
to fine I love this theory that the
internet immediately decoded that these
girls hate Barbie for other reasons and
it's because they're favored after the
Bratz dolls the girls have no names but
Sasha is the name of one of the Bratz
dolls and they do have that same
resemblance Ken is looking at the
world's most ridiculous books most are
self-explanatory like by men rule
literally then we get a book on Cobra
cars guitar for dummies airbrushing
automobiles none of these books are in
the right section he takes a book on men
and Wars by Stuart Scott who was a
construction accountant on the movie the
origins of the patriarchy by Godfrey
Hogarth horses by Ryan Beeson who was
the second AC of the movie This Barbie
box resembles the box for the doll you
can now buy but only slightly it has
metallic lettering for Barbie and the
one in the movie has that 70s font
they've been using looks more vintage
Additionally the backdrop for the box is
the Barbie slide but in the movie It's
the Barbie Dream House regardless they
want to put her back in her box kind of
like her attire in the plastic closet I
like that she's attracted to the box
like moth to like a flame I feel like
it's the same as like a baby going back
to their mama's stomach it's just like
warm it's easy you have no control roll
and that's sort of comforting this shot
of Barbie and Ruth exchanging tea is
supposed to be inspired by the creation
of Adam when we meet Ruth Handler she's
actually making Barbie clothes she has
the small stitch pattern and she's using
the pink white picnic cloth and it's
just so cute when it's revealed that
Gloria and Barbie have their connection
and we go through Gloria's memories
again from her point of view the Billy
eilish song comes back on the what was I
made for
[Music]
then Sasha interrupts this happy moment
asking if they're shining which is the
Stanley Kubrick call out that I
mentioned earlier then we meet Gloria's
husband Sasha's dad who's actually
America ferreira's husband in real life
he's sitting on the couch practicing his
Duolingo and I think he's saying like 10
in Spanish over and over again and he's
just really proud of it then we're back
to Barbie land and the Ken patriarchy
has run rampant we've got a sort of Top
Gun volleyball scene homage here not
only is the new flag a freaking horse
the banner attached to the plane says
Ken and green crayon I hate this place
there's also cowboy hats and banjos
horse riding toys everywhere it's a
disaster it's a mess clean it up back at
Barbie's dream house there's a ton of
horse crap but the painting in the back
of the room of the dogs playing poker
has one one single horse on it I think
that's really funny the Barbie dream
house has become the Mojo Dojo Casa
house which I guess means the vibe
martial arts studio house house it just
sounds nice now two things I want to say
about this Greta said she wrote this
during lockdown and you can tell you
know like lockdown we felt like we were
going stir crazy and some of these lines
that Ken says are just so weird and I
feel like they're the things that her
and Noah bombach would say to each other
just to pass the time so they don't lose
it she also said that Ryan Gosling had a
really hard time saying Mojo Dojo Casa
house because it's a mouthful that's so
many words that mean nothing regardless
since taking over Barbie land the Mojo
Dojo Casa house merch is selling off the
shelves people just love kendam in the
real world and it's gross luckily Mattel
CEO can't and won't have that they must
stay loyal to Barbie and her Mission
also it just feels like you know Will
Ferrell hates Ken's then Crazy Town
Butterfly plays and I'm sorry but I hate
this place even more
they even ruined the pool things don't
sink in the pool because it's fake how
is it sinking they're even playing
Mortal Kombat clearly everything is just
upside down now Ken's truck has the
California Arts play different from the
normal California Plate this one was
created through special legislation and
94 and the proceeds from the plate go to
support Arts education programs across
California so I guess he's good for that
the man who now gives the Nobel Prize of
horses to other Ken's is the love Island
UK star Chris Taylor he got the part
after he met Margot Robbie at an after
party for birds of prey and just like
that Ken kicks Barbie just like she did
to him earlier in the movie he kicks her
to the curb and they cheer it's boys
night the tables have turned but they're
both hurting clearly Barbie after losing
Barbie land and Ken after losing Barbie
Ken starts throwing her clothes out the
open bedroom and they are actual Barbie
outfits to celebrate disco bell bottoms
the ice capades pretty practice suit
pajama jam and Amsterdam set and the
pretty Paisley palazzo pants all real
Barbie clothes then we get this amazing
ad at Barbie's lowest moment advertising
the new sad Barbie even one that's
dressed exactly like Barbie and her
breakdown this new Barbie has such an
unfazed look and dirty sweatpants I
genuinely love her I would buy a million
of these sad Barbies the only thing that
sucks is that she's watching Pride and
Prejudice and she's watching the episode
where Mr Darcy proposes to Elizabeth it
ends saying anxiety panic attacks and
OCD sold separately then the bumper for
you can be anything Barbie blasts on the
screen and this this is a real series
for the actual Barbie at Mattel and they
got to use it when Sasha and Gloria are
leaving Barber land in the Barbie car
the speedometer says zero three 1959
which is the month and year the first
Barbie released the swimsuit Barbie
after breaking the spelling Arthur
Barbie she awakens from a brainwash that
felt like she was invested in the Snyder
cut of Justice League deep cut the
Warner Brothers they ain't letting that
movie slide casually we learn and I
quote by giving voice to the cognitive
dissonance required to be a woman under
the patriarchy you robbed it of its
power basically saying when they finally
realized under the patriarchy as women
their beliefs and actions don't line up
it will unfold and they'll snap out of
it maybe try that in the real life and
Sasha applauds her by calling her white
savior Barbie indeed the Barbie Ambi
Islands they use to save the other
Barbies was designed after weird
Barbie's house that's why it's so
colorful and oddly shaped behind Ken is
a bunch of Ken music and I am ashamed to
say it's Bon Jovi Rod Stewart Fallout
Boy the stone roses The Kooks and like
Sue I I just can't even I just can't
even excuse me I need to go kill myself
and yes this Sublime Sublime was
improvised and killed Margot Robbie then
we get the best song the hottest song of
the summer I'm just Ken Ryan Gosling
reached the Billboard 100 debuting at 87
with this song the song features a
guitar solo from slash and drumming from
Ryan Gosling himself
[Music]
the fellow cans assist with backup
vocals then we get our grease inspired
Dance Off With The Sound Stage
resembling the dream ballet scene from
singing in the rain this song this scene
oh whatever is just magnificent it took
a lot of moving parts and I appreciate
all the work it took to make this song
and get Ryan Gosling on the billboard
100. that's literally insane once the
Ken's finished singing and ride their
invisible horses back to their Mojo Dojo
Casa house it's back to Barbie Dream
Land palm tree is now put back together
with a pink ribbon the Dreamhouse now
resembles the weird Barbie House Greta
also mentioned only being allowed to use
one F-bomb in the movie and how
magnificent it went to president Barbie
cussing out Ken we also didn't get to
see the Barbies wear pants as much
they're usually in their like career
outfits we see a variety of pantsuits
now jumpers and denim president Barbie's
president tracksuit it's like they learn
to even be more comfier when Ken toss's
other Ken his jacket it says Ken fojo
Mojo Ming a jacket that doesn't exist
but this is the first stamp of just Ken
this is Ken's beginning of famed
clothing just like all of Barbies he's
becoming his own star also if you needed
a reminder of how scary Kingsley benedir
is and how great he is at acting that
coat made him realize who he truly is
which is graphic Ruth says I am Mattel
well until the IRS got to me in the 70s
Ruth left Mattel amid the allegations of
fraudulent Financial reports Ruth was
indicted on charges of Fraud and false
reporting to which she pleaded no
contest
so that's where the joke is from the
real Ruth also got a mastectomy just
like she joked about in the movie as
Ruth tells her all about being a human
all the bad and ugly Barbie still wants
to go and we start hearing Billy
eilish's what was I made for again the
lyrics begin with I used to float now I
just fall down just like Barbie did as
she started feeling earlier in the movie
a single tear Falls and Barbie's eyes
open to a shaded view of a bright sunny
Skyline defined by trees blowing in the
wind then we get montages of different
women just just being women and Learners
from their casting crew different home
video footage and Barbie is sort of like
every girl it may be seeing that awakens
a human in her Sasha Gloria and Barbie
are now in the car Barbie's nervous and
Gloria's husband in Spanish says Barbie
I'm proud of you then he says puede
which is a phrase they use at America
ferrera's 2004 hit movie gotta kick it
up but it is also a political statement
for activists so they're both right and
look at our grown-up Barbie sporting
Birkenstock she really said she chooses
the real world then we get our Banger
Closer by Nicki Minaj and I spice
would you different versions of Barbie
Ken Allen and even Midge and that is it
completely it for my re-breakdown to the
digital release of the Barbie movie I
love the Barbie movie you know that I
know that everyone knows that I cried
again while watching it I'm a Barbie
girl follow me everywhere at Lulu
underscore Clements follow new rock
stars and all social platforms bye
Barbie
[Music]
foreign